And I fear that one consequences to your
back,
you got a call is that we are much less
likely to intervene.
Um,
on the one hand there's just a shortage
of troops.
You know,
everybody's preoccupied in Iraq or to
some extent,
Afghanistan.
Um,
on the other hand,
there is a,
um,
uh,
no more stomach for military action.
I think people have just had it with,
with these adventures overseas want the
troops home and are not about to launch
into another one.
Um,
and,
and in a third perspect the Bush
administration is discredited the
concept of humanitarian intervention by
trying to justify the Iraqi war after
the fact as a humanitarian intervention
when we all know that at the time it was
supposedly to have to find the
nonexistent weapons of mass destruction
or was to attack the nonexistent links
with international terrorism.
Um,
but if,
um,
if we knew that there were no weapons of
mass destruction,
if it was clearly there was no all kind
of connection,
um,
Bush would not have gone in just because
Saddam was a tyrant.
Um,
but after the fact by trying to justify
the Iraq war as a humanitarian
intervention,
one that I don't think is justified
because bad is a tyrant,
is Saddam was,
there was not the mass slaughter at the
time that would have justified him.
Manager intervention.
Bush has given the term,
given the concept of bad name.
Um,
he's really tired.
What is I think a very,
you know,
a high minded concept with his fairly
based political needs.
And in the process,
I think it's people say like the people
in our four core paying the price.
Um,
because you know,
why is the international community only
willing to go into dark for with the
consent of the Sudanese government,
you know,
consent that has been held for a very
long time.
Um,
it's because there is no more,
you know,
stomach,
there's no more capacity to,
to use military force,
but also because people are not
skeptical of this concept of
humanitarian or convention.
And so in that sense,
the people that are four or of eastern
Congo or,
or others facing mass atrocities are
very much paying the price of this,
um,
this cheap resorts to war and an effort
to justify it after the fact,
as a humanitarian action.